and we're just going to break away
briefly from that downing street
briefing because there is some more
breaking political news
uh the leader of the opposition's office
uh on behalf of sakia stamina have just
announced that the
former leader of the labour party jeremy
corbyn will
not at this time have the whip restored
so he will cease to
continue to be unable to operate as a
labour mp
within parliament this of course follows
the decision by the party yesterday
following a statement from him uh to
re-uh
select him as a member of the labour
party but he is being
excluded uh from the labour
parliamentary party let's get a little
bit more
uh from our list of correspondent tom
rayner
yes adam following that decision by
labour's
uh national executive committee panel
yesterday to reinstate
jeremy corbyn's membership there were
questions about whether or not that
meant
he would now be a labour mp once again
allies of mr corbyn have said had
claimed
uh this morning that that would be
automatic however it's clear
that kia stammer while he cannot do
anything about the decision of the
national executive committee to
reinstate the membership the party
membership of jeremy corbyn
he does have power to prevent him
sitting within the parliamentary labour
party and in a statement that he's
released he says i'm the leader of the
labour party
but i'm also the leader of the
parliamentary labour party jeremy
corbyn's actions in response to the ehrc
report
undermined and set back our work in
restoring trust and confidence in the
labour party's ability to tackle
anti-semitism
in those circumstances i have taken the
decision
not to restore the whip to jeremy corbyn
i will keep this situation under review
this
adam will create a backlash there was
going to be a backlash one way
or the other uh because if kia stammer
had accepted that jeremy corbyn
uh could retain the whip i understand
that there were those in the shadow
cabinet who were considering
uh their positions there were threats
from other back bench labour mps that
they too
uh would resign the whip in protest
kierstarma
chose instead to risk the backlash of
the labour left and there are plenty of
mps still very loyal to jeremy corbyn
who
are likely to be extremely angry by this